to me marketing is about values this is
a very complicated world it's a very
noisy world and we're not going to get a
chance to get people to remember much
about us no company is and so we have to
be really clear on what we want them to
know about us now Apple fortunately is
one of the half-a-dozen best brands in
the whole world right up there with Nike
Disney Coke Sony it is one of the greats
of the greats
not just in this country but all around
the globe and but but even a great brand
needs investment and caring if it's
going to retain its relevance and
vitality and the Apple brand has clearly
suffered from neglect in this area in
the last few years and we need to bring
it back the way to do that is not to
talk about speeds and fees it's not to
talk about MIPS and mega Hertz it's not
to talk about why we're better than
Windows the dairy industry tried for 20
years to convince you that milk was good
for you it's a lie but they tried anyway
and the sales were going like this and
then they tried got milk and the sales
are gone like this got milk the thing
talked about apartment that focuses on
the absence of the product
but-but-but the best example of all and
and one of the greatest jobs of
marketing in though if the universe has
ever seen is Nike remember Nike sells a
commodity they sell shoes and yet when
you think of Nike you feel something
different than a shoe company and their
ads as you know they don't ever talk
about the product they don't ever tell
you about their air soils and why
they're better than Reebok their souls
where's Nike doing their advertising
they they honor great athletes and they
honor great athletics that's who they
are
that's what they are about Apple spends
a fortune on advertising you'd never
know it you've never known so when I got
here we Apple just fired their agency
we're doing a competition with 23
agencies that you know four years from
now with tip one and we blew that up and
we we hired Shaddai the ad agency that I
was fortunate to work with years ago we
created some award-winning work
including the commercial voted the best
ad ever made 1984 by advertising
professionals and we started working
about eight weeks ago and what was the
question they asked was our customers
want to know who is Apple and what is it
that we stand for where do we fit in
this world and what we're about isn't
making boxes for people to get their job
done although we do that well we do that
better than almost anybody in some cases
but apples about something more than
that Apple at the core its core value is
that we believe that people is passion
can change the world for the better
that's what we believe and we've had the
opportunity to work with people like
that we've had an opportunity work with
people like you with software developers
with customers who have done it in some
big and some small ways and we believe
that in this world people can change it
for the better and that those people
that are crazy enough to think they can
change the world are the ones that
actually do and so what we're going to
do in our first brand marketing campaign
in several years is to is to get back to
that core value a lot of things have
changed the markets a totally different
place than it was a decade ago and
apples totally different an apples
placing it is totally different and
believe me the products and the
distribution strategy in manufacturing a
totally different and we understand that
but values and core values those things
shouldn't change the things that Apple
believed in at its core are the same
things that Apple really stands for a
day and so we wanted to find a way to
communicate this and what we have is
something that I am I'm very moved by it
honors those people who have changed the
world some of them are living some of
them are not but the ones that aren't as
you'll see you know that if they ever
use the computer it would have been an
act
the theme of the campaign is think
different if the people honoring the
people who think different and who knew
this world forward and it's it is what
we are about it touches the soil of this
company so I've never had well with and
I hope that you feel the same way about
it I years to the crazy ones
The Misfits rebels troublemakers round
pegs in the square holes
once you can see things
they're not found
they have no respect the status quo you
can quote them disagree with them
glorify or vilify them not the only
thing you can't do
and while some may see them as the crazy
ones we see genius because the people
who are crazy enough to think they can
change the world ones who do
you
you